Okay, I need to talk to you about something
that's really important today and I need some
time to lay this all out for you, but hope
it'll be productive.
Yesterday I started getting emails and seeing
comments saying, David, will you disclose
your funding and will you disclose whether
you're getting money from a pro Bashar Al
Assad group that is in existence to prop up
the Syrian regime, disclose your funding and
tell us who your funders are.
And it seemed like a weird thing to ask of
me.
I didn't understand why are people coming
to me and saying, am I getting funding from
a, from a pro Bashar Al Assad group?
So I started researching this and then I saw
a couple of reports and posts that there are
several left wing independent media people
that have allegedly received money from a
pro Assad group, some under the guise of a
journalism award, money that was awarded a
for winning a journalism a prize.
So I want to do this and I'm going to give
you the full breakdown of our revenue at the
end of the segment.
But let's go through this and actually try
to do it right.
So let's begin with what are the allegations?
The allegations are that several left wing
independent media hosts and writers and publications
received money from a group called the association
for investment in popular action committees.
It's a very sort of innocuous name, uh, but
investigative reporting by Charles David,
uh, claims to demonstrate that this is actually
an umbrella organization that is a covering
for and the sort of a, a name place holder
for a, uh, groups that are pro Syrian dictator
Bashar Al Assad.
The association for investment in popular
action committees has a trademark called the
serious solidarity movement, which again,
it sounds pro rights, but it's, it's pro Assad.
And the idea here is that this is an umbrella
group for pro Syrian government organizations.
When you look at them on GuideStar, it's very
innocuous.
It's a civil rights advocacy group organized
in 2007.
There's limited information.
It's headed up by two guys, Paul LA, Rudy
and Kemal obeyed.
And when I started looking into this, and
this is all new to me, I've, you know, I did,
did the research over the last 24 hours, obeyed
has said that he was a member of architects
and engineers for nine 11 truth, which is
a nine 11 truther group.
I would call it a conspiracy group.
So it's starting to get a little bit weird.
And the revelations that have come forward
for independent media are that this group
has created something called the Serena Shem
award for uncompromised integrity in journalism,
which awards money to different media people.
They've paid former Ohio governor, a democratic
governor, Dennis QSEN.
It's $20,000 to speak at a proba Shar al-Assad
conference in the United Kingdom.
And, um, it's so happened that Cousineau synNotch,
uh, opted not to condemn Assad a few years
ago.
And it turns out that some people, including
former TYT host Jimmy Dora, Dory, I don't
know how the name is pronounced now, as well
as YouTube or Kim Iverson, who I didn't know
much about, and many others have received
money from this group through this award.
Now let's go, go through it.
Uh, there are some trends that exist here.
Both DOR and Iverson have done a combination
of questioning the known facts about Bashar
Al Assad and have started to dabble in some
conspiratorial false flag stuff as well.
Both DOR and Iverson have put out content
that is very pro Tulsi Gabbert and Tulsi has
her own sort of history with Assad.
That has been the subject of scrutiny.
There is an IRS filing, which you can easily
find online, uh, from the pro Assad group,
which shows that in 2017 DOR receive $2,500
from this group while Kim Iverson previously
posted to Instagram that she received $5,000
from the group.
So the first question is, can we trust the
allegation?
In other words, did these people and the others
that are listed in the piece that we're linking
to, did they receive this money?
Iverson admits she got the money, she posted
about it.
And unless the IRS filings are false, DOR
did as well.
There's a longer list of people you can find
online, but the part one, did they get the
money?
It appears that they did.
So then we have to ask, well, even if it's
a pro Assad group that is funding the award,
uh, are they, is, are they getting money to
say certain things or are they merely being
awarded for the things that they're already
choosing to say?
And I think that this is an important distinction
with a lot.
We've talked about this before.
You know, that it's common that people at
Fox news, people at RT, Russian television,
they'll say, nobody ever comes in and tells
me exactly what I need to say.
And of course it doesn't work that way.
It's not say this stuff and then we will pay
you.
It is often that people are selected for roles
on the basis of what they're already likely
to say.
So we really don't know the, the, the reality
of this.
That's one thing.
Uh, then there's this issue, you know, it,
it correlates with the pro Tulsi stuff and
alternative facts around Syria and related
topics.
This is odd, but ultimately it's their business.
Now, if it were me, I would disclose this
stuff full-stop.
I mean, I don't, I don't have any other way
that I would qualify it.
I would just disclose it.
So then we come to me in the emails I've been
getting over the last 14, 16 hours saying,
David, you're part of this, disclose your
funding.
We want to know where you get your money.
So I'm going to do that.
First of all, I don't know why anyone would
think I'm getting money from a pro Assad group
or pro Assad sources, uh, particularly that
are peddling and you know, uh, were their
leaders, uh, the, this obeyed guy pedals in
nine 11 truth or stuff or anything?
I don't do any of what they do.
You know, I, I don't do Assad apologetics.
I don't do pro Tulsi apologetics.
I don't do any of this stuff.
But I'll just come clean and tell you our
funding.
This is from a normal month.
This is data from August the [inaudible],
it's the beginning of October.
So I haven't closed the books on September
yet, but this is a typical month.
This is a August.
We got 40% of our revenue for memberships,
Patriot and apparel, 32.5% from YouTube ads,
22% from ad sales, three and a half percent
from Twitch.
As many of you know, we're new to Twitch.
So that's a pretty small part of our revenue
right now.
Facebook ads, we're now monetizing on Facebook,
but only about 1% of our revenue and miscellaneous
donations are 0.1%.
Now those miscellaneous donations of course
could come from anybody.
Uh, but what I'm talking about is sometimes
people don't want a membership.
They'll just send us, you know, a check for
a little bit of money.
Uh, and that was 0.1% of our funding back
in August.
We don't take money from any groups.
If we have an advertiser, it's marked as an
advertisement.
If we do a sponsored video, it's marked as
a sponsored video.
That's it.
So I can't speak to the strategy behind other
people's actions.
I have no idea what people's financial situations
are and what would cause them to accept or
not accept money from an organization like
this.
Everybody's financial situations are different.
And also, I don't know if what people are
concerned about is that the content of these
programs is influenced by the fact that they've
received money from this group or if people
are concerned about the lack of disclosure
or something else.
And it would be interesting to clarify that,
but T to be very clear, um, people are often
chosen for awards because they're saying the
right things.
And of course the award can be a way to funnel
money to someone under the guise of we are
rewarding you for good reporting or whatever
the case may be.
But typically that's not how it works.
People, people are brought in, uh, or supported
because they're already saying the things
that the funder wants them to say.
So that's our funding.
I can't speak for anybody else and I hope
that this will sort of put to bed the questions
I've been getting over the last a half day
or so.